françois legault promet l'accès à la
haute vitesse partout au québec d'ici
ça va être fait d'ici maximum deux en
relais sur le terrain on s'impatiente
tarif est dans les dernières années
malgré toutes les preuves et ce malgré
des investissements d'argent c'est que
le déploiement des réseaux prend du
temps 2017 environ 340 mille foyers
québécois n'avaient toujours pas accès à
la haute vitesse
depuis le gouvernement a donné le feu
vert à plus de 150 projets de
branchement
mais en septembre dernier à peine 7000
foyers de plus étaient desservies jean
audet habite au pied des laurentides à
une heure de montréal
en l'absence d'une bonne connexion le
télétravail devient difficile voire
impossible
son fils a dû déménager en ville
principalement à cause du manque de
réseau monfils le il travaille un
multimédia
alors lui peut pas vivre ici si le
déploiement de la haute vitesse et si
l'un c'est parce que l'installation
prend du temps pour chaque poteau
utilisé il faut un permis et il y a des
délais chez bell on explique que chaque
modification des infrastructures doit se
faire en suivant les normes du crtc
l'accès au poteau des gens démunis
pertes et des mercis qui ont investi des
sommes incroyables et qu'attend à
vouloir juste installé leurs équipements
l'accès à la haute vitesse partout
prendra encore du temps la preuve des
documents du ministère de l'économie
révèle qu'en 2022
plusieurs projets de déploiement de
réseaux seront toujours en cours de
réalisation et certains ne seront même
pas encore commencé ici vincent
maisonneuve réseau canada montréal